there you go
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
given to the king and queen as they
leave Buckingham Palace and come round
the Queen Victoria Memorial
and they will then turn and head up the
malware an enormous number of people
have been waiting but they'll also pass
by the grandstand which packed out
earlier on today with people getting a
chance to see the king go by
the third and fourth
positions of the sovereigns escort
following him behind the carriage taking
the king's procession
foreign
hip hip hooray the crowds cheered the
grandstand are on their feet to catch a
glimpse of the Diamond Jubilee State
coach as it goes past they've been
waiting so long and this the moment to
catch a glimpse of the king and the
Queen on the way to their coronation a
historic moment for all those standing
by here at Buckley Palace and on the map
[Music]
oh
[Applause]